the pressure is just overwhelming I
don't want to disappoint John I don't
want him to think that he's signed some
Disney kid Selena Gomez breaks down in
tears over her struggle to shake off her
Disney image Disney channel is
definitely a machine they they obviously
care about a show they want to make it
the best and they give everything they
can into one thing and each of their
projects Selena starred on the Disney
Channel's hit series Wizards of Waverly
Place from 2007 to 2012. no
I'm gonna let them enjoy their Alex free
day because because I'm that nice I
worshiped Disney when I was younger and
still to this day you know High School
Musical and everything and and so just
to be on there on their network is just
a blessing and I'm thankful and in her
new Apple TV plus documentary my mind
and me the triple threat gets emotional
during a rehearsal for her 2016 Revival
tour admitting she's worried her concert
feels too young and it might disappoint
the execs that signed her to Interscope
Records that was a moment in 2016 she's
getting ready to do her first tour
outside the Disney uh you know machine
uh and she was at that tender age of 24.
but that wasn't the only tear filled
moment Selena had thinking about her
past as a child star
[Music]
I needed to lose you to love me while
promoting her emotional ballad lose you
to love me in 2020 cell got upset after
she felt like an interviewer wasn't
listening to her heartfelt answers I
feel like I'm a product
it was like making me angry
you know they know what it is it made me
feel like just
it's a trigger I don't I just like I've
spent years years of my life trying to
not be that it's
[Music]
oh no that's cool
look like a witch
but the outfit doing it all like the
wand again
whatever it's about it but back in June
Selena opened up about life after Disney
on the Hollywood reporter's Awards
chatter podcast and said she's grown
from the experience and looking back
she's nothing but appreciative for those
years I am so grateful because
everything that I've done I've earned
and I've worked really hard for and I
would never replace that for the world
if everything was handed to me I
guarantee you I would be a totally
different person when people even say
the whole Disney chapter of my life you
know oh do you regret it or no it was
hard to kind of move away from it but it
wasn't it TR it really did train me
[Music]